oh no is the baby gonna turn to a stove
what's going on reject nation greg and
john
here we have to reshoot the intro for
ryan the last dragon
because i messed something up anyway
guys this is gonna be a movie reaction
here uh it's reaction highlights
obviously can't
show the whole thing gonna do our best
to keep this visible on youtube but
full-length watch along if you guys want
to sync up with us uh we're putting that
over at our patreon
if you're one of me who bought the
premiere access come join us for that
come join us we got a whole bunch of
other stuff at our patreon
that's so sexy all these shows and
movies or a couple of movies and mainly
shows i mean look at all these
thumbnails
lastly i gotta thank lisa slinger
messed up her name when i uh filmed this
while i'm on a roll lisa thank you so
much for editing these reaction
highlights for us
uh she is the apprentice of eric the
nerd chronic the man who normally edits
our
tv reactions movie reaction highlight so
lisa
you're gonna do a great job you already
have i feel it we also did an interview
after watching this
i encourage you to go ahead check it out
sweet digs
what the hell is that what the hell is
that
i don't know what is she writing on
a lone writer a dystopian world
yes these are my thoughts how did this
world
get so broken
dragons magical creatures who brought us
water
it was paradise that's beautiful but
then i love when they choose an
alternate art style for like the
prologue
the what came you were talking over the
droog
the dragons fought for us the best they
could
but it wasn't enough how do you defeat
such an enemy
that's when the mighty sisu. the last
dragon
concentrated all her magic into a gem
and
sold the gem made a lot of money
people being people they all fought
to possess the last remnant of dragon
magic
yeah i agree
this was the right choice
this is this movie just like saying
let's get right into it let's just jump
right in
oh you want action here we go
let's show my clever really looks like
what are you oh i love it we need to
open up an amazon wishlist
so we can get that just took some porgs
tuk tuk you're my new favorite disney
character
[ __ ] over my batman filipino shirt what
the hell is wrong with me
oh those steps look so freaking real
[Laughter]
this feels too easy
challenge accepted i know it's your job
to try and stop me but
you won't is this like some trading
course
don't mistake spirit for skill
yo the crash zooms in this movie
you lost raya did i
one toe you did good dewdrop
you're past the test the spirit of sisu
hmm i wish your father was as cool as
his
yeah you know hers you know what i meant
to say i'll work on getting a new dad
for me for you
whoa alkaline water
it's so balanced it has no h on that
[Laughter]
the doors were sealed and they never
left the stones
[Laughter]
oh what about flaming catapults
an ak-47 lemongrass from
talon bamboo shoots from spine chili's
from fang
and palmer are you gonna try to
peacefully communicate whoa
they're only our enemies because they
think the dragon gem magically brings us
prosperity damn this soup looks good
i want some soup really does look good
let the blood bath begin oh it's easy to
pontificate on kumandra
when you hold the mightiest weapon in
all the lands
this escalated smoothly who's hungry
go ahead it's all right you two look
about the same age
be friends you're the only other child
here i'm the one wearing the sisu fan
necklace
come on have you eaten yet
fandom brings people together
uh racers too
i didn't think that'd stump you too far
ryan
fang may look nice on the outside but we
have some pretty big holes on the end
you are called fang
but if we could find it could you
imagine
a dragon back in the world things could
be so much
better the power you could wield
from one dragon nerd to another
hey come with me dublin i want to show
you something
oh what if she's like manipulating ryan
i know what if the whole goal is for her
to take her right to the dragon
chat yeah thank you debla
you've been there ah crap we were right
damn it
oh oh you two little girls
what are you doing that's good good try
nice nice 540 there
oh
uh guys time to go i am not a i'm not
happy
sorry it's fangs now
ryan you defend the [ __ ] out of that gem
oh cool
wow cool oh cool
yo yo daddy heart
what is this making a play for the gym
no it's fine
ah [ __ ] or we can come together
and build a better world
it's not too late i still believe
we can be commander oh no oh no he put
his sword away
oh no
you broke the tesseract no
yeah this is why you don't put your
faith in people
ever
whoa wow no
what an effect
there's still time to be opportunistic
no
get like a squirt gun
that is a freaky effect but with the
right gem they could reverse it
yes oh
oh
there's disney again killing off the
main character's parents
what a what an emotional rollercoaster
the last 24 hours she's been on
made a new friend only to get stabbed in
the back
oh is that
uh what's your guy's favorite
uh kim no to no the thing she's writing
oh oh is that tuk tuk tuk tuk yeah is
that tuk tuk like grown up
maybe dang you got big in six years
oh god this is a desolate wasteland yeah
it is
wow
he's still adorable
oh she's looking for the dragon you know
i just remember the trailer
seem like you're going cold figuring out
stuff
you're so easily distracted
oh god and water repels them and there's
no water inside
yeah this is this is a good place to be
a drone it's just some malevolent entity
everywhere they go
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
it's kind of like our friendship yeah
my back hurts
[Laughter]
that's not a bad sign is it
possibly one of the worst wrecked ship
him in the middle of the desert
no you're not going to turn around ryan
look at him
i made a mistake i trusted someone i
shouldn't have
and now the world's broken
damn that is a lots of weight on someone
for years on end
just really really want my paw back
please
it's beautiful yeah i mean the just the
textures and the elements are
insane and you're
people oh what's your name right right
is that food there are a few
things i need to catch you up on oh yeah
yeah oh no if you lost a puppy
and i said well we're still
yeah i wasn't the one who actually made
the joke oh no
turned it in oh no oh
every dragon has a unique magic okay
what's yours
i'm a really strong swimmer
[Laughter]
if we can get all the other gem pieces i
can reassemble it and
pull the drone away and bring my bob
back and bring
all of kumandra back
wow she's just like
sprung right into believing in herself
all it takes is a little comrade i
thought there's gonna be a lot more
doubt for a while it's like hey we can
do this
oh it's fangirl all growed up
at least get a different hairstyle lady
i'm retrieving some useless dragon
scroll it's been worth the risk
stupid man why would she show raya the
map
when they were young if they were trying
to get to the gym that's a good question
this place didn't just poopy drop itself
it's the old-school version of a laser
maze
if they know gymnastics they can do it
if they oh look she's just doing it like
a normal person i was to say
she's not just doing a bunch of sexy
flips
it's kind of refreshing huh i'm a wicked
when i hit that liquid
i got water skills that kill i slaughter
when i hit the water
aquafina wrote those rhymes
why is it called
[Music]
a tootin boom the hell
oh oh no
from the looks of it she was hoarding
the gem and became a victim of her own
traps
well you gotta admire her commitment
it's like you said at the top gonna live
in here and starve with the jazz
can't dragons fly ah
maybe not in this world
two down three to go
uh oh what uh
akin to people
that's not a very nice way to describe
an old friend
namari what's dripping deploy
what's driven here i was worried you
were gonna end up becoming a cat lady
like me hey
yeah cats are awesome oh is that why
you're chasing me
and here i thought it was because you
missed me
i do i actually was looking for cesium
oh and guess what i found her why would
you reveal that yeah why would you
reveal that especially in human form
murder and we'll entomb ourselves in
here as well
[Laughter]
oh gross oh
they even got the sound effects i wish
your dad's farts were that beautiful
it might not be so taboo
[Music]
you were just kids she was doing what
her mother indoctrinated her to do
they're afraid of water they're afraid
of water
i hate water too well that's a major
weakness if they can't go into the water
yeah if they can't even like get across
or deal with the water
oh that's handy
oh how cool you know that was cool
that's nice this movie's so fast-paced i
know
[Music]
hey man we got like three other
territories to get
so fast
oh that looks so good why is the food
look so delicious huh
should have eaten before this what if
this
is poison
you're gonna die happy
i love the soundtrack yeah i really do
this is one of the most distinct
in like uh one of these disney flicks in
a while
i mean their common ground seems to be
their appreciation and connection with
the dragons
maybe that part wasn't a lie this is why
i never leave the boat
you're a smart kid i mean they look kind
of beautiful at night
yeah they do plus it's got to help you
see out here
they're like a relentless fire that
consumes everything in its wake
until there's nothing left except ash
and stone hmm like john's dad
man this is this has been really
illuminating for me
i really take for granted the beautiful
animation it's just like it's supposed
to look that good
it's literally moments like that where
i'm like oh they just slip in like a
real shot of water
but it's a hot spot for pickpockets and
con artists lucky for me
empty pockets so here's the good news i
know where the generals
what danghai lacks in style he makes up
in
yeah he looks like a ruthless [ __ ]
this guy
if you see any hungry faces send him my
way
you got it captain don't listen to raya
no go out there
cause some havoc
you're yeah by water have some fun wow
some people call attention to yours
as much attention as you want yeah
don't trust that baby
i mean yeah just a baby check out the
baby
toddler thing what are you
doing oh no
oh you little con artist baby knew that
baby was up to no good
that's it i'm going shopping yes yeah
you're an adult you could just put it on
credit oh
[Laughter]
just get on quad pay or clarna or one of
those
the reason why our country's in debt
this mentality is what you're teaching
kids
she has a sword dried eats two dragon
gem pieces no we don't no
you've been identified get away from her
in time come here can't you see she let
slip important information we can
exploit
you better kill that baby raya yeah you
teach that baby a lesson
fruit ninja
[Music]
disney plush show that's a plush show
get a spin off
make it happen
a lot of poop and fart stuff here okay
man the the action is so well directed
it's
so well done
using your baby charm to rip people off
i know baby where's my stokie
oh don't fall for a ride you could eat
him
she's just a victim of larger
circumstance
how would you like to earn some honest
loot
you wanna pull up the heist yeah i'm
assembling a team
this is a great show you guys we have
been so
bored you don't even great choreography
you guys said
where are shanghai right over there
oh no the most vicious chief
talon has ever seen
those folks
[Music]
chief that height is just outside the
city
beyond the gates away from the water huh
well away from the city he runs
as chief
oh god oh god uh oh it looks
hungry
[Music]
so there's there's like there's like no
good people in this world nope
except for that that baby's learning
well we're stuck with them for a while
because angie's have nine stomachs oh
i'm sorry where's the baby's parents
they're frozen
we gotta go find them and load them onto
the ship
[Music]
she doesn't steal your teeth why would
she steal your teeth
truly growing into the leader i raised
you to be
ready the royal army for my daughter's
command thank you mother
i won't let you down i don't trust the
mom yes i'm too easy about that
i don't trust her and that'll be the key
to getting raya and her on the same page
do you want to play hide and seek on the
boat
so we're all hiding in the water yeah
well the world's broken
you can't trust anyone sounds like
you're dead dude i have learned so many
terrible things in this life and
they're all being reflected at me now
kumandra is a fairy tale
the only thing important to me now is
bringing my bob back
um maybe in order to do that you need to
learn to trust again
trust all these horrible people
just just never give or receive gifts i
think that's
even this kid wants money in exchange
for this
okay yeah i can see how that makes me
look like a liar actually i think it was
the lying that make you look like a liar
i'm not sure what's funny
do you plan on doing with us oh it's
going to be bad
horrifying take me two weeks to clean up
you it'll be too easy to clean up
will you help us please
that's all it takes to build real trust
is a common enemy
hey there princess undercuts fancy
you're nothing without your band stand
down
my ego's hurt i wonder who's like mocap
to this
i would be i wouldn't be surprised yeah
yes yeah oh
why are you stealing gem pieces oh i'm
just trying to get a matching set
damn oh and make those punches hurt
oh i'm gonna enjoy this
what
you you don't look so uh look at your
set
i'm scary pete peace out wow the whole
world
changed in a split second for her you're
not the only one who
lost family to the drone
yeah she's the most important one
my big brother's magic
rain i mean the junior afraid of water
right oh absolutely
yo yo
and she's off she just never returns
ah steve trevor taught you well
time to kill that mom put her in her
place
the only way in or out
there always seems to be like a bit of a
heist vibe to this movie yeah
a lot of this mixture of animation yeah
confront namari and offer her something
nice and though
hey
i've been waiting for someone to ask me
here you go
best friends forever
i hope that does happen
oh dad this is where it all happened
500 years ago huh
we we're the last dragons
oh well sweet let's hope we get some
flashbacks
this is where we would make our last
stand
united
the last stan x-men united oh definitely
the best x-men
is i trusted them
and they trusted me
or they just wanted you to suffer
who are all going down you're gonna
watch
[Laughter]
i once thought that we could be friends
after all this for like
10 minutes you wouldn't just bring your
bob back
he'd also bring back his dream kumandra
and people seem really shitty in this
world
so distrustful your dad was like the
last good person
what do you think she's into cats knives
cats with knives
knives with little cats on them actually
i know exactly what to give her
hey
all right all right now run along
kittens
i have to speak with the princess i get
like a secret jafar
vibe from her yeah a little bit when
everyone comes back
who do you think they'll come for you
forget the other lands blame us for
what's happened
but we we never meant for anyone to get
hurt but but it's your fault
we could save the world but more
importantly
but more importantly
[Laughter]
what are you going to do that's no
longer your concern my love
you've done enough i like how she
doesn't play full villain
she still seems like a compassionate
mother yeah just like yeah he just got
some messed up point of views
that's good though i like
i that this is the first baby heist i've
ever seen
and it kind of reminds me of the
penguins in madagascar
that's a good call
there's always time for a snack there's
got to be a disney plus spin off of them
in the works
they're so freaking adorable that's a
cool
top huh
like the bar thing i'm just taking
fashion tips
from this movie man being a pervert is
what you're doing that's right
she's got a great body and she's got
and she's built too she's got muscles
and i appreciate that
it didn't shy away from making her a
little buff
oh my gosh let's get some food
i got your message our shards in here
i never thought i'd see this again well
uh it's a fake
it's definitely a trap guys
[Music]
the final piece time to bring everyone
back
don't come any closer whoa what
i don't have any other choice yes you do
i got this
smasher i know you don't want to hurt
anybody
what are you doing you just want a
better world manipulated you
connecting i trust you no more
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no
[Music]
oh that's real bad oh that got me yeah
damn it
oh she go hulk out oh god oh god
it appears that with the last dragon god
so too goes the warrior
oh there's nothing to stop the drone oh
no wow
oh golly you know this guy is so
dark oh there's no water this is oh
we're gonna end on a cliffhanger
oh she mad oh she mad she's gonna be had
the queen of fang herself
yo this just got
super cool get in there
let's finish this
happen off camera
there's good people look for the helpers
oh god
great action yeah damn it's so good
but you didn't trust her
that's why we're here do whatever you
want
what you had a pretty itchy trigger
finger there
good people
she got benevolently batmanned
it's just like the city shot from
avengers
damn it favor repaid i just want you
ladies to get along
[Music]
oh god wow oh
that's intense it's got so dark
like the last 20 minutes
then let me take the first step
oh there's a gift
put your goddamn gems together
hurry up you just sacrificed herself
oh no is the baby gonna turn to a stone
oh
come on combine the damn
yeah take that
ah dunes the dragons coming back too
oh probably
[Music]
now it's going to become a really
abstract 80s
[Music]
i want to go back to the trailers i feel
like i had a prediction about the the
villain her being like a change
just like prove myself right yeah show
off my trailer predicting
skills instead of a review we should
just post that clip
oh wow hold it they all coming back
oh no it's like a lucky charms
commercial with dragons
reborn
no one's even saying hi to her no one
yeah not a single word
i'm sorry i shot you
she's my favorite character yeah
oh her dad her dad
everyone's family and the blip
people finally live in the city again
[Music]
they just returned the baby go travel
find your way home yeah you guys are
good right
we'll drop you off
you are hallucinating my friend
oh it united everyone
everyone's back
hell yeah
oh that's great even even villain mom's
beer
oh that's cool welcome
this is
well done
that's beautiful the last
30 minutes of this is so good it's
really yeah this really
rose to the occasion oh
god it's not coming out of my nose
well done not bad hey
what's up your dad was all right by the
end of it i think you'll see that he
brought himself
around all right all you need is a
little trust
he can do it
our own little arc as well here yeah
i'm like about to go home and have a
very tearful reunion
that's wrong john this
fake scenario crack made up that was not
detailed at all
it really got to me and i'm just i'm so
happy to see you
no one else could be you
all right guys well i gotta keep this a
little short
a really hungry b
shooting this on the day when that
spider-man tutor reveal came out so it's
not much sleep
it's been a day i'm just gonna be very
direct
it's good it's good done three and a
half to four out of
five stars honestly i was a little bit
worried because i wasn't in love with it
the first half
i was enjoying it the animation
undoubtedly beautiful the music in here
is wonderful on a first viewing too
maybe one of my favorite
out and out sound tracks for just
grabbing me and also pulling me in
i love the voice work especially from
kelly marie tran and gemma chan in this
movie i thought they were great
i loved the villain yeah she was like
my favorite in this whole thing i love
the baby
the action scenes like all the technical
stuff was really good and like
the production design and everything
they brought to life and i love the
mixture of animations
interwoven throughout the story yeah
honestly it's like i think it was really
good i kind of would have liked
a little bit more of that finale tone
just spread out throughout the movie a
little bit more if that makes sense like
that darkness loom yeah like let it
sprinkle and build to kind of your epic
dark finale
that finale just really made up for a
lot and even made the earlier parts
better for me there were parts of it
that i was like
i wish this would just kind of take its
time a little bit more and let us live
in the world
as opposed to being kind of told and
kind of undercutting some scenes with
humor
yeah and living a little more within the
conflict aside from just the moments
where it's escalated to the point where
we're about to fight or something like
that
when it becomes the conflict that just
has boiled over to the point that even
getting the dragons
shards together might not work it's like
that's what it really feels like the
stakes transcend
it felt like the first disney movie i've
seen that was like could he use an extra
half hour
to like to like flesh it out and let
because it's such a big
world and created that's grounded yeah
and i'm like but in order to really feel
the stakes and the peril it shouldn't
move this quick
yeah yeah because it does sort of seem
like with the group of us
together we can all pretty much kind of
solve this although i do
like that they had part of the first
half of the adventure beat
everyone tried to hold on to these
shards and hoard them
even though like yes they do repel the
droon like everyone's insistence on this
has led to these gruesome
lonely abandoned towns it's that thing
of like
man each of these places is different i
kind of want to stop at each one of them
and
soak up the vibe and whatever once it
really started to push into that like we
have to like cross
difficult ground to the people that we
you know see as our enemies sometimes
when it really
dives into that theme is when this yeah
started to really punch above its weight
to me
yeah i mean it might be actually earlier
on when it really started to hit me it
was
was when namari gets confronted by
sisu the first time when sisu is in
dragon form
right when you sense that maybe there's
a change here yeah
yeah like it was that it was that
particular moment because they do allude
very early on when they're passing the
stone dragons and she does the heart
yeah shape that like oh okay so the
connection to the dragons could be the
way to change her heart
we got to like her finding the dragon
really quick yeah i thought that'd be
like at the half i was like i was
surprised
we got right to that and then it's just
kind of goofy yeah yeah
so that's what i mean it's like that
that sense of peril and feeling the way
the world's being affected as opposed to
being told is kind of just what was
missing but as things started to settle
in especially with getting sisu's
backstory there
i thought it might have been something
like oh you were the dumb dragon you
were the dragon who like no one really
lied why'd you survive and you have to
prove you're
they shoved you in because you sucked
and they thought they could expend you
yeah but then you got kind of a more
mysterious element to
why she was the one who was chosen which
i did appreciate it but yeah i mean that
last half hour
i was like crying my eyes out you know
yeah the last half hour just makes
the rest of the adventure actually feel
better it would have hit me a lot more
in the feels
earlier on even like movies like frozen
two which are not pixar but disney
animated get pretty heavy and dark
yeah and i wouldn't have minded it
committing more to that scale throughout
yeah it's not that there's not conflict
or anything like that but it does
it certainly seems like it upgrades in
caliber once we get to a certain point
it's not even a bad thing to me it's
like it starts out fine
and then it gets pretty good you know
yeah that's that's what i mean like it
feels okay like
granted like i said animation voice over
work music
fight scenes all are awesome absolutely
from beginning to end
it's just the actual storytelling i
wasn't that impacted by until like
halfway through it remember two dudes
we're not i i i couldn't relate to this
at all we're not gonna
say we're two guys maybe not the ones
who were most
credible to comment on such a thing i
grew up in like hong kong cinema so
movies from like michelle yo and cynthia
rothrock
were movies that i just sort of watched
as a kid and i'm half asian a half
filipino
so watching all the like the
representation in this movie
even though it's like takes place within
this asian world
i wasn't like look how freaking asian he
is
like or look at all the wokeness on
screen none of that was feeling like
shoved in my face even though it's like
predominantly female characters here
what i loved about that was none of it
felt like preacher in my face
that's the part that actually felt like
really natural and lived into me
and was it wasn't trying to be like look
how feminine and look how
asian we are even though it's all there
yeah it didn't feel like
shoved no and yeah it just felt natural
that these would be the two
characters in the position yeah that
were and i yeah yeah it was nice when
you're not even thinking about it no
that wasn't really that i think
that's all i'm trying to get to is like
i didn't even think about that until
right now or not like oh yeah that's
kind of a funny thing to know yeah you
don't get to halfway in the movie and
you're like wow how
weird it's two chicks and they're both
like the main fighters
yeah like i like that that stuff played
pretty naturally and i think that's
helped along by the fact that you do
have a diverse range of even if they are
you know uh
fictional regions and stuff you know you
do at least get to see
various iterations of power and society
in this world and yeah i did like the
fighting too i mean i think you said
something wondering if it was mocap and
yeah i mean like especially because i
feel like in
animation we get a lot of like visuals
and slapstick and stuff like that but i
feel like less of the time we see an
action movie heist movie
in this format and i thought with that
stuff like the actual
fights and the actual like weaponry and
stuff like that i thought that was
gorgeous and i like the theme too of
trying to look for the good in people
and the trust yeah yeah yeah trust
that's the word i don't think the movie
really
they said i don't think they said that
word they said it specifically
trusted us to be able to pick up
yeah i do i just want to harp that one
more time is beyond the prologue that
when they even did the flashbacks to
certain things they would incorporate
2d or things that look like paper
cuttings or stuff like that
i thought that was the coolest that's
some of my favorite stuff too and i
think it's great to get namari who's
like an antagonist who they really set
up as like a villain from early age yeah
rivalry to be the one who i found to be
the most compelling character yeah and i
like that overall it's like yeah you do
have like
these villain things popping around and
you have people with very much conflict
between them but at the same time
it's apparent that the circumstance
and the perspectives on it are really
the villain
in terms of raya i like how she's a this
character who seems very
positive but they don't shy away from
playing into her distrust of people
yeah and it gives her that edge so that
like when it came to the finale after
sisu was shot with the arrow and she's
like marching into town you're like oh
damn she's just she's gonna say
yes the movie felt like it got there
very natural with ron
that's what i mean is like a lot of
things that weren't working for me
in the first half really started to
click for me by the time we got to that
finale yeah
i think in terms of building to that it
all does flow pretty well
all right guys what do you think of raya
and the last dragon
did you love it did you like it were you
disappointed
is it right in the middle for you leave
your thoughts down below we'd love to
hear all kinds of opinions on it you
know we're open-minded folks so
let us know what you thought subscribe
click the notification bell
hit that like button patron of the day
sarah campbell i'm not doing the big
arms for your shout out
but you're one of the most badass ladies
over on patreon but that didn't go up
here though
i went down here just incremental change
is what we're going for sarah and i
think you could help me with that
because you're an adventurous
young lady i was creeping on your
instagram
and much it's judge she followed me and
i was like i wonder what sarah's life is
like and it turns out
sarah billy's back ladies all you gotta
do is follow john
he's gonna go snooper on your instagram
oh yeah just keep that account public
but you're a traveler you've been so
many places that i've never been to that
i would love to go and i hope that in
this new year you're able to strike back
out into the world and do some more
exploring this movie put me in sort of
an exploratory mindset there are a lot
of beautiful lands on display
you've seen probably at least a place or
two
this was based on yes forget it she's
traveled
shout out completed i hope you're doing
good